In Winnie the Pooh: Blood and Honey,
a bloodthirsty Pooh hunts for his
unsuspecting victims. Here's a
look at the beloved character,
now transformed from a honey-loving
bear into a walking nightmare.
Ever since the Winnie the Pooh: Blood and
Honey trailer hit the Internet back in August,
it has become clear that this is not
your average Pooh flick. Very loosely
adapted from the work of A.A. Milne and E.H.
Shepard, the film purports to introduce Pooh
as a bloodthirsty beast hellbent on eliminating
all humans from his path. As for Piglet, well,
he doesn't get off too easy, either. In this
version of the story, the adorable pig is now
a total psycho swine who will further
Pooh's murderous mission at all costs.
Just like his character, Pooh himself has been
distorted beyond recognition. Grotesque and
barbaric, he strikes the imposing figure of a
beast, all while wielding a terrifying plastic
grin. And while Pooh's appearance makes sense in
the context of the film — Pooh is essentially a
mindless animal now, clobbered by life's cruelties
— his soulless face still sends chills down
any Pooh fan's spine. But the best part is that
the actor who plays him looks completely innocent.
According to Blood and Honey's
director, Rhys Frake-Waterfield,
the new Pooh is nothing like the
friendly bear that children have
loved since the early 20th century.
As he explained to Variety last year,
Pooh and Piglet were left alone long ago by
Christopher Robin in the world of this film.
"Pooh, Piglett, Eyeore. We were friends
for many years. And they’re out there."
He told Variety,
"They've essentially become feral. They're like
a vicious bear and pig who want to
go around and try and find prey."
Naturally, a formidable-looking actor would
have to take on such a terrifying role. But
Craig David Dowsett is, by all accounts, an
average guy. He's still an up-and-coming actor,
so he hasn't done many interviews yet, but
he's perfectly charming in those that have
made the rounds so far. On top of that, he's
already set to appear in another horror film,
so Blood and Honey fans can expect
to see more of him in the future.
Before now, Craig David Dowsett's only
acting credit was for the horror flick
The Area 51 Incident, which was also directed
by Frake-Waterfield. But after Blood and Honey,
Dowsett will appear in yet another horror film,
The House that Zombies Built. Not much is known
about the film yet, but Dowsett is currently
credited as "Roger the Zombie Easter Bunny," which
could signal another childhood-destroying
role as a beloved fantasy figure.
But perhaps most auspicious for future fans of
Blood and Honey is the news that Frake-Waterfield
plans to make more childhood-ruining cinematic
adaptations of beloved fantasy figures. As he told
The Hollywood Reporter, he's already cooked up a
story involving an evil Peter Pan and overweight
Tinkerbell, who is recovering from drug addiction,
in Peter Pan's Neverland Nightmare. Additionally,
Frake-Waterfield plans to make Bambi: The
Reckoning, which will tell the classic story
of a rabid baby deer who seeks violent revenge
upon the humans who sought to destroy his life.
Of course, since Dowsett and Frake-Waterfield
have collaborated twice now, it tracks that
they might continue their working relationship
on Frake-Waterfield's future horror outings.
After all, Dowsett looks appropriately
horrifying in his low-budget Pooh get-up,
so it's not hard to imagine him filling in the
shoes of a larger-than-life, fanged Bambi — or
of a lumbering, deadly Peter Pan, for that matter.
Now, we can only hope that Blood and Honey drums
up enough hype to fund better costumes for
those hypothetical horror flicks of the future.
*Screams*